everyone I'm David Griffin now Michael
Medina here bring it to a nice long
break arrow a long time yeah I'm a
little bit of arrow tonight that's a
season 2 episode 10 blast radius this is
a you know we're back you know that's
it's kind of funny back good to be back
a lot a lot went on the lat in the first
half of this season it sorta talked
about like wait where are we right now
it's like okay so episodes 10 blast
radius a new villain in town yes they do
Firefly alum yeah the only problem is
there's no some regardless episodes Dean
I could complete both of that's okay
that's okay um you know I gotta admit
now you know like every single review
i've been talking about much i love the
show ranting raving every episode has
been great oh I feel something though I
get him coming no but i gotta admit it
wasn't one of my favorites okay it
wasn't bad i'm not saying i definitely
enjoyed it and stuff but i felt like and
i don't want to say it was a fill-up so
cuz it certainly was not no it's just
for whatever reason maybe I just wasn't
feeling the villain as much you know but
I thought it was a good episode but just
you know no I would agree i think this
isn't the most dynamic villain we've had
though I was happy to see something I
got from firefly this he wasn't as
dynamic as some other villains you know
especially we were introduced you know
Deathstroke is in town I thought we
might see him again I was I'm gonna see
him next week maybe with the preview you
see like that you know the mask but
especially was all him in Grundy the
best parts on this episode again I don't
wanna give Laurel too much credit i
don't know if she's her character still
interesting but at least brother blood
makes her more interesting yeah which
was nice to see him kind of sad though
that you know like laurels kind of
depending on this this ya know what i
mean right I'm liking brother blood the
more I see him cuz I mean you really
just after what happens to Laurel
discovers that his mother was actually
he's a double that oh right yeah Appa
something like all right that's a nice
little I mean you kind of saw it coming
I guess you know very familiar with the
character but if you're not it was a
nice little twist Breck sweet when we
talked about brother but the first time
we went through was history a little bit
on this on you know on think hero and
talked about how you know you have to
commit an act of patricide it to kill
your father to join the group and to
become the next you know patriarchy is
here so we knew that he probably didn't
kill his dad it wasn't you know infirm
his mom as a kid which is crazy so he's
bad
uh let's see those as we get a little
bit of a Roy yeah we're finally starting
to see something that that you know the
the shot kind of game now so he's shown
some signs of like super-strength right
I don't really know how much yet right
you can see like his arm heals yeah he
gets you know the beam falls on him he's
ok now we know that he's probably not
overreacting or not getting too hyped up
too crazy because he does have you know
speedy here's a girl so that's gonna be
holding them in worse I'm assuming yeah
I think you're probably right because I
mean he's definitely reacting to it
differently than Slade yeah right so we
cut to the flashbacks and we see Slade
just looking like he's juiced up on
roads or something like that you know
and um and again that going to the other
Island I'm loving what I see an island
of it was too short this week it really
wasn't nothing to say anymore yeah you
did more I think they're just again this
is a 22-episode season so I need to hold
back enough to last the whole season but
I wish we could see more absolutely I
thought that was definitely the
strongest part of this particular
episode and stuff and and you know I
didn't want it to just be about shadow
getting killed and that's what you know
kind of brings Oliver and Slade to in
her heads but you know you're starting
to feel a bit more they're gonna live
deep marino Oliver's you know obviously
he's struggling with trying to keep this
secret I guess where it feels
responsible for shadows death or whatnot
so but uh yes late kind of goes off and
does his own thing alright often is
short but sweet and you know we we had
to mention this being a CW show we have
talked about olicity or look it's not
going yeah oh listen yeah so let's see
looks like they're gonna keep it as
friends here's his baby she was in the
central city on a little vacation you
know being visiting action going on
though yeah yeah yeah Oliver questioning
where her heads at they were closed you
know yeah it almost happened like were
they gonna kiss you know we got after
this is C dub we have to have the
relationships going out here but it is
III like Philistia I like their
relationship yeah and it's like with the
relationship it's complicated obvious
yes you know I mean you saw what
happened between him in Laurel last
season and stuff he can't just
especially like somebody that you work
with right you know i mean that's that's
tough and I I was pretty sure I you know
we weren't gonna see any we might still
hold another half we might still see
something but I don't wanna rush sounds
like that either you know what I mean
you've got some drama right i mean
listen he's not dead is the kid going to
keep happening hiatus that's a hiatus
right now so I mean how do we like how
do we think this episode looking in the
future like what do you what are we
thinking for the next the next half of
this to the Somme well I think the
mid-season finale just set up the second
half so well yeah even though this
episode for me was just kind of there
it's so good it was still good i'm still
hyped up for this because there's still
so many possibilities because we still
have Cyrus you know mention in the
episode yourself brother blood and then
we have you know Deathstroke's later
we're gonna need more of you know and I
pray going back to what we said about
Laurel her role this season and stuff
I'm really hoping we get something out
of this character because at times I
almost wish she wasn't even in an
deputies still popping pills yeah if
you're just gonna stick around give her
a couple lines whereas for the sake of
putting up it's like just you know what
I mean it doesn't help I'd like to see
more from she's not doing anything on
her own I want to like her yeah I know I
think cuz we have to kick but you can't
kick butt but it's just not we're not
seeing it right now yeah so I mean you
know another another great episode on
the good episode maybe not as good as a
you know mid-season finale but arrow is
back we're happy that it's back let the
the mayhem begin with a lot of episodes
to get through still to get to 22 or
only on episode 10 right now so stay
tuned you know for reviews and keep
following this you know as always you
come chat with us at think yo calm we
also can come find us on this YouTube
page when a comment you know we you know
you see Mike and I in the comments you
know always like try to respond to all
your comments so you know sure if that's
what you think is think you're a pro and
we're also on Twitter at think here and
talk to Dennis myself Mike but
personally i'm at griffin de and i'm at
mr. michael Alexis we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think your fans will be sure to give us
a like thumbs up this video subscribe
spread the word you know more more air
oh goodness to come as those at least
continue so yeah we'll see you next time
you